today the Matt wall show yet another
prominent Beauty brand tries to sell its
product to women by using men dressed in
Woman face also garage door victim Bubba
Wallace has a temper tantrum and tries
to kill another driver during a race but
his victim status ensures that he will
face no serious consequences plus a
daily wire report reveals what sources
inside Vanderbilt have to say about
Vanderbilt's pledge to pause gender
transitions on minors and don't believe
Your Lying Eyes Joe Biden says that the
economy is actually strong as hell quote
unquote in a daily cancellation Airline
passenger is accused of fat shaming for
complaining about being wedged between
two morbidly obese people for a
three-hour flight who's in the wrong
there we'll talk about all that and more
today on the Matt Walsh show
foreign
[Music]
the labor Department's Consumer Price
Index which catalogs the cost of good
Services food and rent Rose 0.4 percent
over the month of August double what
many economies or economists had
anticipated perhaps worse core inflation
which excludes food and gas prices saw
the highest increase last month that
it's seen since all the way back in
August of 1982. what's the current
Administration doing to quell The Surge
of inflation well they're spending more
taxpayer dollars of course don't bury
your head in the sand while your savings
deplete diversify into gold with Birch
gold today Tex Walsh to 989-898 and
burps gold will send you a free info kit
on protecting your savings with a gold
with gold in a tax sheltered account the
experts over at Birch gold have almost
20 years of experience in converting
IRAs and 401ks into precious metal IRAs
with an A plus rating with a Better
Business Bureau countless five-star
reviews and thousands of satisfied
customers why haven't you checked them
out yet Now's the Time to do it gold has
always been your best hedge against
inflation Diversified savings can
protect you from downturn in the market
if you have a 401k or IRA that's
underperforming just text Walsh to
989898 and you can convert that into an
IRA and precious metals right now Birch
gold group has an A plus rating With
Better Business Bureau countless five
star reviews and thousands of satisfied
customers I already read that text Walsh
to nine eight nine eight nine eight and
berts go will send you a free info kit
on diversifying into gold tax free take
the necessary steps to hedge against
inflation today and protect your
hard-earned money get your free info kit
by texting Walsh to
989898 now
you know there was a time not very long
ago when uh women's cosmetic and Beauty
Brands would cater very specifically to
women they would arguably go over the
top in that regard every ad you know was
about how special and wonderful and
unique and beautiful all women are just
the way they are which always did raise
questions as to why they would need the
products in the first place if they're
already special and and beautiful just
the way they are but the brands were
they were pandering and they were
pandering in a way that made sense to
the customer base that they were trying
to reach that all started to change a
few years ago first was the announcement
of the first dude Cover Girl James
Charles in 2016 and this prompted a sort
of nuclear arms race of wokeness uh with
other women's Brands rushing to find and
feature their own cross-dressers doesn't
make a lot of sense from a practical or
business standpoint
these companies are still predominantly
selling to females I mean really only
selling to females and the point of a
model for a fashion or cosmetic brand is
to demonstrate what the product looks
like the female customers want to know
what the product looks like on a woman
not on a drag queen but the race was on
in any case other Beauty Brands jumped
in last year Revlon tweeted a picture of
a guy named David Lopez bearded yet
caked in makeup with this caption
can we talk about how beautiful David
Lopez's look is it's all in the in the
details ColorStay concealer candid glow
Foundation ColorStay satin ink in your
go to
001
and eyes on you 006 I don't know what
the most of those words mean but I do
know what beautiful means and I know
that this picture ain't it
David Lopez's look could better be
described as ridiculous grotesque ugly
it appeals to almost no one on the
planet
see the walk left they applaud this
stuff in principle but few of them
actually find it attractive
because it's not about being attractive
or beautiful anyway
the fashion news site nylon profile
Lopez a few months ago and applauded him
for quote
demystifying and degenderizing the
beauty space yes degenderizing
that may be one of the more annoying
fake words we've heard in recent years
but the greater point is that this is a
campaign to take femininity away from
women to de-genderize it the point was
driven home a few days ago with the
launch of a new podcast hosted by Ulta
beauty which is the beauty brand that
owns hundreds of salons all over the
country in an episode titled the beauty
of girlhood posted to Ulta Beauty's
Twitter page the degenderizing David
Lopez interviews quote unquote trans
woman
big scare quotes around that Dylan
Mulvaney now you may recognize that name
because Mulvaney has been all over the
place recently the media's latest and
greatest trans mascot most recently we
talked about he was a featured speaker
at the Forbes Women's Summit
and he came to prominence due to a
Tick-Tock series called days of girlhood
which documents his quote transition
from man to girl not man to woman you
may note but man two girls specifically
he identifies this is a grown man who
identifies not just as a woman but as a
girl
this transition as the videos uh
document on his Tick Tock page mostly
consists of him prancing around while
doing an exaggerated over-the-top
impression of femininity you may recall
this particularly degrading example here
it is again
day 66 being a girl and today I'm in
nature
trees I love them
water lakes I love them
heels they're my hiking heels I love
them
Bridges love them
coconut water love it not mad just love
it
wind turbine love it Meadows love them
did you see
let's see I'm scared of getting Lyme
disease
[Music]
you know I've been hiking in the woods
with my wife many times she does not
wear high heels and spandex for the
occasion in fact she wouldn't wear that
combination for any occasion least of
all a stroll through nature that's
because my wife is an actual woman
like a real one Dylan Mulvaney has
transitioned not into a woman but into a
cartoon and yet corporate brands in the
media have made him into a spokesman for
Womanhood which leads to this podcast in
which two males discuss the beauty of
girlhood
and that is where this is said listen
now I know I can find love I know I can
still be a performer I know that I can
have a family I want to be a mom one day
and I absolutely can and that's why the
narrative still has a long way to go
because when I was grieving boy Dylan I
didn't know those things were even
accessible to me
a mom one day he says that's that's all
it takes you know put on some lipstick
and uh stick a red bow in your hair
and suddenly the rules of biology no
longer obtain you could be a mom
for soggy things yeah unfortunately for
Dylan if he ever wakes up to find his
belly distended it's not going to be a
human child in there it might be you
know maybe he contracted a parasite from
some bad Sushi or else maybe he's about
to reenact that scene from Alien but
whatever condition afflicts him he we
can be sure that the maternal experience
will always elude his grasp
now this discussion about girlhood
continues for almost an hour with two
men again discussing the beauty of
girlhood not Womanhood girlhood I'm not
going to subject you to to much more of
it but I did find this portion
interesting where the two men give their
thoughts about the nature and definition
of beauty listen
the beauty really is it's the potential
I don't think Beauty for me is like an
end goal or like a one thing you know a
one look or a one specific moment it's
it's the ever-changing potential to see
myself in a light that makes me really
happy yeah that's so special and I mean
it's one of the many reasons I love you
and adore you and what you do and
um why people I think relate to you
because there's this idea and this
concept that we as queer people we are
the stewards of change of this new world
because we are willing to live our life
joyfully through adversity and willing
to love ourselves
despite the world telling us we
shouldn't
there's certainly many criticisms we can
level against these two but we cannot
accuse them of having a low self-image
that's one thing we can't say that is
not a problem often evident on the LGBT
left where they tend to carry around
such massive and Hefty egos that you
wonder how they manage to walk upright
or fit through door frames we note as
always that the self is put at the
center here Dylan defines Beauty as the
ever-changing potential to see myself in
a light that makes me happy now that's
wordier than it needs to be because
these people are allergic to speaking
clearly but the point is that beauty is
simply whatever makes them feel good
truth is also whatever makes him feel
good Womanhood is whatever makes him
feel good literally all of life every
part of life is defined by its ability
to make him feel good about himself
everything really has the same
definition
and no definition at all at the same
time
of course this is not just nonsensical
but incredibly demeaning and defensive
there is no substantive difference
between this
and a brand using a white guy in
blackface to Market to black people
and the insult becomes all the more
outrageous when you consider that
Mulvaney just quote became a woman or a
girl sorry a few months ago as a tick
tock stunt
now now he he not only claims the title
for himself but even deems himself
worthy to speak for women
he hasn't experienced any of the things
that women uniquely experience he hasn't
encountered any of the challenges that
women uniquely encounter he hasn't paid
the toll that women have to pay
you can't relate to being a woman he has
absolutely no insight to offer on the
subject he puts on a Minstrel show
and we're expected to act like it's the
real deal
now the good news
is that a great many people seem to be
tired finally of pretending
of playing along
I've been waiting for the moment when
most of society gets sick of this
garbage
this nonsense that we we have all always
recognized as nonsense
and now finally it seems like lots of
people don't want to play along anymore
the reaction to this Ulta beauty
campaign has been almost uniformly
negative the company has disabled the
comments on YouTube and on Twitter
because almost every comment was
critical
women in particular are speaking out and
now a boycott movement is growing
now I myself have been boycotting Ulta
beauty since the day I was born but the
hope is that actual customers will
follow through and refuse to give their
business to a company that advertises to
them by degrading and demeaning them
this should be uh in a a really a really
easy decision
you know there's like just no reason why
you should give your money to this
company ever again
in a just World Ulta beauty would be
bankrupted and destroyed by next month
which is what needs to happen
you know it's one thing to be tired of
the appropriation and degradation of
Womanhood
but now the people responsible for it
need to feel the consequences
and that's the only way to make all of
this
stop finally
now let's get to our five headlines
we're celebrating a huge win this month
and a fight against tranzing the kids
with Vanderbilt Hospital agreeing to
pause all gender transition surgeries on
minors but the fight is far from over
there is still so much we can do to
protect our children from this evil
leftist Insanity one thing you can do
today is write a will many new parents
don't realize how important it is to
have a will in place but the sad truth
is that if you were to die tomorrow
without a will the fate of your children
will be left up to the state I don't
know about you but I don't want the
state deciding anything for my family
luckily my partners over at Epic will
make nearly will make early estate
planning incredibly easy and affordable
they bundle your last will your living
will Health Care power of attorney HIPAA
release and durable Financial power of
attorney plus you can save 10 percent
when you use code wall should only cost
119 for a single person to create a will
and when you use promo code Walsh you'll
save 10 so go to epicwill.com use promo
code Walsh to save 10 on Epic Will's
complete will package that's
epicwill.com promo code Walsh
by the way Media Matters uh this is hot
off the presses they have their latest
hit on me they're passing around today a
clip of me for my all access on Friday
where I say that anime is satanic now In
fairness
somebody asked me in the All Access how
I feel about anime
and I I said that I have no argument for
this
no argument really to support it it just
feels satanic to me it seems weird and
bizarre and kind of demonic that's the
vibe I get okay that's it's a Vibe
that's all it is it's a demonic vibe
I have to explain that's the whole point
of the vibe I don't have to explain it
just is
so anime and yoga both satanic
what else do you want me to tell you
that's how that's how I it's my lived
truth that's how I experience it the
great thing is that I said this but
here's the point I said this on Friday
on an all-access
which means first of all that Media
Matters they not only watch all of our
content but they are all access members
they are they are in fact our highest
paying they have paid for our highest
paying membership status our uh most
expensive membership in order to you
know watch everything we do and
everything we say and they want to
because especially they want to get the
off the cuff which is what all access is
by the way if you're not an all-access
member uh like Media Matters is then are
you gonna let Media Matters
support the daily wire more than you do
come on
should all be all access members but
this is you ask questions you get our
off the cuff answer and if you ask me a
question about anime and want to get me
talking off the cuff about it this is
what you're going to get
I stand by it 100 can I necessarily
justify it
no but that never stops the left they
can't justify anything they say
so why should I have to
it is satanic in fact I'll go a step
further and I'll say
based on what I understand if you watch
anime
for up to 30 minutes in a row you will
become demonically possessed
that's what Studies have shown that
all right let's begin here it's pretty
rare that we covered NASCAR on this show
I can't pretend that I'm much of a fan
though I had respected it for being the
only unwoke professional sports league
if you can call NASCAR sport which is a
different conversation but uh it was
unwoke for at least it seemed to me that
it was and that is until Bubba Wallace
had a panic attack over a garage door
pull and uh NASCAR responded by trying
to turn him into a civil rights hero and
all the other drivers fell to their
knees before him and they did a 21-gun
salute and a fighter jet fly over and
they awarded him the medal of freedom
the Nobel Peace Prize because he because
of his he was traumatized by his garage
door
all of NASCAR's unwoke credentials went
flying out the window in one Fell Swoop
because of that
and that was also the last NASCAR
related story that I was aware of
until this which also features garage
door victim Bob Wallace from the daily
wire test NASCAR driver Bubba Wallace
erupted into a fit of rage during a race
on Sunday as he attacked another driver
after causing that driver to crash the
incident happened during stage two of
the South Point 400 Las Vegas Motor
Speedway when Wallace who won stage one
was next to driver Kyle Larson when
Larson attempted a three-wide pass
Larson moved up the track and his car
gave a slight tap to Wallace's car
causing Wallace's car to brush up
against the wall after brushing up
against the wall Wallace bounced into
Larson's car and then continued by
tracking Larson's car down the track and
slamming into the rear of his car
causing both cars to spit to spin out
and we have the footage of this incident
which is what led up to everything uh so
here it is
you don't see a lot of NASCAR
Wallace Jackson
just play bumper cars going 180 miles an
hour
and they both spin out
and nobody was seriously heard from what
I understand but that's it just so
happens that nobody seriously hurt so um
going back to the DIY report says after
both cars came to a stop Wallace who has
previously been described as being
self-righteous and smug got out of his
car and physically attacked Larson who's
smaller than Wallace or so tried to get
away from Wallace and the physical
attack was only stopped
when NASCAR officials intervened so
here's here's that part
now they get out of the car
trying to be a tough guy dressed like
Ronald McDonald
tough guy in the Ronald McDonald uniform
last scene sobbing over a scary rope in
his garage
but he's uh he's tough and scary and
unfortunately the other dude who's at
Kyle Larson just like runs away from him
but there's a reason why he runs away
we'll get to that in a second
so to review bubble walls gets angry
um Rams his car into another driver
going 180 miles an hour 200 miles an
hour
which is essentially attempted murder I
mean you could easily kill somebody
doing that Wallace should face criminal
charges for this you could kill someone
um but then he gets out physically
assaults the guy and later being
interviewed by a reporter he continues
to be of course childish and petulant
blaming everyone but himself because
what else is he going to do let's listen
to that
what happened Cliff Daniel said if that
wasn't retaliation I don't know what was
was it intentional retaliation on your
behalf Clint's smart enough to know how
easy these cars break so when you get
shoved into the fence like deliberately
like he did trying to force me to lift
steering was gone so just so happened to
be there
um hate it hate it for our team
um fast super fast car had no short run
speed as you were saying we were kind of
falling there Larson wanted to make a
three-wide dive bomb never cleared me
and uh I don't lift so I know I'm kind
of new to run up front but I don't lift
so I wasn't even in a spot two lift and
he never lifted either and now we're
junk so just a piss board move on his
execution when situations like this
happen Bubba at this speed is
retaliation an acceptable thing stop
fishing stop fishing I'm not fishing I'm
just asking you let's also talk about
the message you wanted to send to Kyle
by going up to him after the incident he
knows he knows that what he did was
wrong
uh he wanted a question what I was doing
he never cleared me so
um just paid it for our team our
McDonald's Twitter camera was super
solid just needed to find a little bit
on the short run get the balance where
we needed it and it would have been just
like Kansas but now the car's jump
there's always unintended consequences
when something like this happens
Christopher Bell was a part of that
clearly a Toyota teammate and a playoff
driver your reaction to that
Sports
okay uh so she says the reporter stopped
fishing stop fishing he's asking you
questions about what you just did so
he's I mean he's fishing for an answer
but like directly asking him so
apparently no big surprise Wallace has a
reputation for being an enormous brat
and a crybaby
um although now he's escalated to
actually trying to murder his fellow
drivers because he's upset he had this
reputation In fairness before he was
traumatized by a garage door which only
which only makes their humoring of him
during that incident all the more
egregious
they knew that he was an attention
starved primadonna and they went along
with it anyway
and now he's basically empowered to do
whatever he wants act how he wants
because of the victim points that the
incident afforded him
uh and he's probably McDonald's won't
even drop him you got McDonald's logo on
his uniform on his car while he's trying
to kill somebody and is that going to
mean that McDonald's will drop him no
they won't they can't because of the
victim Point says victim Point said he
somehow retained
despite the fact that everyone knows
that it was a hoax with the garage door
that was confirmed they sent 15 FBI
agents to investigate and even they
couldn't find a reason to call it a hate
crime they weren't there to investigate
they were there they were PR okay this
was a public relations crisis and they
sent the FBI there as a PR move and they
were trying to figure out how can we
bail bubble walls out of it out of this
how can we come up with some way to call
this a hate crime and even they couldn't
do it
despite their best efforts
speaking of law enforcement
you think again if law enforcement was
going to get involved in a NASCAR
related incident it would be here where
a driver smashes his card and someone
else intentionally trying to cause an
accident
but that again won't happen because of
Bubba Wallace's victim points so this is
a this is a good lesson for us
it shows us once again what happens when
we Empower these cry bullies this is
what happens when we vindicate and
validate a person's feelings of
entitlement
Bubba Wallace is pretty clear is someone
who has never been told no in his life
Just Like Jesse Smollett like you don't
end up in this acting this way
if you'd been told no
he's never had the the character
building experience of being told now
and without that character building
experience you have no character
you can't have character integrity
dignity as a man if you don't know how
to deal with frustration loss defeat
I guarantee Bubba Wallace he was the
kind of kid who would like give fall and
scrape his knee and start crying
hysterically and rather than having a
dad who would say hey son you're fine
rub some dirt on it you're fine get up
you'll be you'll be okay just run it off
rather than having that he was fond and
pampered over and he learned that as
long as he is upset or sad or pretending
to be he gets all the attention he wants
and that with attention he gets power
attention is power
and he's brought that strategy with him
into his adult life
and now look at him
the only remedy is the word no the only
cure to force people like this to
confront harsh realities just tell them
no
they come along crying about the garage
door pull pretending that they're a
victim of racism you say no you're not
just no get over yourself yeah but I
feel like I am it it still hurts me yeah
that's your problem I really don't care
grow up Bubba
describe
but he wasn't told that in fact if I
remember that that incident correctly
even after it was revealed because it
was pretty pretty quickly it was
revealed that that whole thing was it
was not real and like you did those of
us with two brain cells in our heads uh
we knew from the beginning even before
the the photo came out or there's any
investigation the moment we heard that
someone planted a noose in a NASCAR
garage
the moment we heard that we're like no
that didn't happen it just it didn't
happen
but then but then very quickly was
confirmed that it wasn't a noose and yet
NASCAR
even still said that they were going to
mandate sensitivity training and
unconscious bias awareness training for
their employees
despite the fact that it was just a rope
to to uh pull up and down the garage
and you end up with this self-entitled
brat all right
uh
here's a story from the daily wire this
is kind of exciting because I have the
physical they handed me this this hat
this literally just came across my desk
I have the physical paper with the story
just feels a lot more official when you
read it from here this is actually
important um
so this is a headline Vanderbilt and
Insider sphere transgender surgeries on
minors will resume
so as some employees at a Top Tennessee
hospital were relieved to learn last
week that it will freeze transgender
surgeries on minors but told the daily
wire only a law could ensure the
practice which can include the removal
of a minor girls breast ends for good
Vanderbilt University Medical Center
suspended pediatric gender surgeries
under pressure from State lawmakers
but three medical professionals who work
or have worked at vumc all speaking on
the condition of anonymity we're
skeptical that the pause would become
permanent one source told the Telly wire
quote Vanderbilt is a liberal-led
institution anytime anybody lets
pressure off they'll continue to push
these types of procedures uh Second
Source said it won't stop until it's
banned by law in this state
um
yeah last month the footage shared by
the daily wires Matt Walsh of a vumc
doctor referring to reversible
transgender surgeries as huge money
makers prompted the sources to come
forward each Source said that they were
extremely uncomfortable with transgender
surgeries on minors being performed at
the hospital and that many of their
colleagues were as well but a few feared
retaliation from the hospital if they
were able if they were to speak up with
their name attached to it a third Source
said quote many of us aren't okay with
what's happening so these are sources at
Vanderbilt who work there
but still even though Vanderbilt has
said that they're pausing these
procedures uh still the people working
there who are sources don't feel they
can't say anything publicly
because of the um
of the
consequences that were
alluded to in in one of those videos
that we uh revealed
in a statement announcing the pause vumc
said they've performed double mastectomy
surgeries on girls at least 16 years of
age on an average of five per year since
their pediatric gender clinics Inception
in 2018 But A source told the daily wire
that they have first-hand knowledge
that at least 10 miners have received
double mastectomies this year which is
double what vumc says is their average
the daily wire has not been able to
independently confirm these figures so
these are people
again working at Vanderbilt
who say that you know they Vanderbilt's
claims that they're pausing the
procedures
and all indications are that they are
right now which is a big victory because
it is going to save in in real time and
in real terms it's going to save
children right now from being mutilated
big victory big deal
but
there's no reason to think that the
pause will be permanent unless the law
has changed and we do also know that
well at least according to One Source uh
what Vanderbilt claimed in their letter
saying that they're going to pause what
they claim does not comport with the
facts
so what does that mean it means that we
have to keep our um
foot on the gas there's no reason to let
up quite the opposite
which is why I hope to see you at our
rally which is on Friday again this is
Friday October 21st at the state capitol
here in Nashville will be at four
o'clock so we need as many people there
as we can get
and this is
about showing lawmakers
showing the country I mean showing all
politicians showing the culture that
people people care about this this is
just unacceptable we are not going to
tolerate this
We're Not Gonna tolerated in this state
we're not going to tolerate anymore
so I hope to see you there on um
Friday
all right you may think that it seems
like the economy is in rough shape but
Biden while chopping on his ice cream
says that uh actually
that the economy is as he puts it strong
as hell it turns out let's listen
I'm concerned about the rest of the
world
that makes sense can you explain that
yes our economy is strong as hell
in the internals
inflation is worldwide it's worse off
everywhere else it is in the United
States
so the problem is the lack of account of
growth and sound policy in other
countries not so much ours and that's
how it's worldwide inflation that's
consequent
okay well hard to understand what you're
saying there uh because he's got a
mouthful of ice cream and also there's
all the noise in the background but he
said he said the economy is strong as
hell you know here's the thing I don't
need politicians to pretend
that they feel our pain I don't need to
feel like they're just uh one of the
common men in everyday American as they
like to say
I don't need for a politician to be the
kind of guy that I want to have a beer
with we always hear about that
especially around election time uh
what's which which you know voters want
to vote for the guy who they feel like
they could sit down and have a beer with
I don't care about that I wouldn't want
to have a beer with any of these people
uh even the good ones I'm not sure I
really want to sit down have a beer with
them so I don't need that but I do need
to see
that they at least intellectually in
theory
understand and appreciate the severity
of the problems that Americans face
um
I already know that they're insulated
for most of those problems
especially politicians in DC most of
them are independently wealthy and they
you know so they don't have to worry
about the economy they don't live in the
in the parts of town that are
you know gripped by a violent crime
epidemic so they don't have to worry
about that plus they have armed security
all the time so I know that they're
insulated from it but do they at least
understand intellectually this is
happening
I need to see some sign of urgency and
with Biden and the rest of the Democrats
there is simply none of that
they don't care
they deny that it's a problem they
fluctuate between denying the problem
exists and then sometimes they'll say
well yeah the problem exists but it's
actually a good thing
but what the undercurrent running
underneath all of that is that they just
they just don't care
and it's it's not even that their their
solutions to these problems are
bad or counterproductive it's that they
don't there are none they're not even
trying to solve the problems
um here's a really interesting article
from Bjorn lomberg in the financial post
he says it's easy to believe life on
Earth is getting ever worse the media
constantly highlights one catastrophe
after another and makes terrifying
predictions with the never-ending
torrent of Doom and Gloom about climate
change in the environment it's
understandable by many people especially
the young genuinely believe the world's
about to end but the fact is that though
problems Remain the world is getting
better we just rarely hear about it we
are incessantly told about disasters
whether it's the latest Heat Wave flood
Wildfire or storm yet the data
overwhelmingly shows that over the past
Century people have become much much
safer from all these weather events in
the 1920s around half of a million uh
people were killed by weather disasters
whereas in the last decade the death
toll averaged around 18 000. this year
like both 2020 and 2021 is tracking
below that why because when people get
richer they get more resilient but it's
not only weather disasters that are
getting less damaging despite dire
predictions a decade ago
environmentalists loudly declared that
Australia's magnificent Great Barrier
Reef was nearly dead killed by bleaching
caused by climate change the Guardian
newspaper even published an obituary to
it this year scientists revealed that
two-thirds of the Great Barrier Reef
shows the highest Coral cover seen since
the records began in 1985. the good news
report got a fraction of the attention
the bad news did
um not long ago environmentalists
constantly used pictures of polar bears
to highlight the dangers of climate
change polar bears even featured an Al
Gore's terrifying movie and Inconvenient
Truth but the reality is that polar bear
numbers have been increasing from
somewhere between five and ten thousand
polar bears in the 1960s up to around 26
000 today we don't hear this news
however instead campaigners just quietly
stopped using polar bears in their
activism okay this is the part that
really interested in me
um
because I I didn't know that either I
just like like most people I don't keep
track of polar bear news and so this is
just something I remember hearing about
this since I was a kid that polar bears
are almost extinct and I just kind of
had that bouncing around in my head I
hadn't really looked into it
and it turns out that you know the polar
bear situation is uh much better than it
used to be he goes on to list other
indications of improvement in terms of
climate and economy but the bit about
the polar bear is fascinating because
he's right we heard incessantly about
the polar bear crisis their pending
Extinction and then suddenly
the chicken littles on this particular
topic just stopped talking about it
nobody ever came around and said hey uh
good news everybody
polar bear situation is fine now you can
stop worrying about polar bears
I've spent the last I've spent 36 years
of my life worrying deeply about polar
bears I wake up every morning worried
about the polar bear situation
no one ever told me that they're
actually doing okay
because that's what they do they just
stopped talking about it they move on to
the next Crisis
you hear about the problem
and then you stop hearing about the
problem
but you're never told that the problem
was solved
and what is the effect the effect is
that
our minds are just
assaulted by Panic and doom 24 7.
and they they never give you the glimmer
of light at the end so you got the
problem the problem the problem and then
at the end you should have oh here's the
good news here's what happened with that
but they just no we're gonna we're gonna
leap from that to the next one
and
you know here's the thing that there
there are always crises in the world
there's always an impending Armageddon
there's always going to be
if you live on planet Earth
there are always really bad things
happening
um
there's always the potential for
disaster lurking around the corner and
it could come in many different forms
that always exists
you know
um there are always going to be species
of animals that are either on the verge
of Extinction or actually have gone
extinct
like 99 of all animals who ever lived on
earth went extinct before human
civilization existed
so you're always going to have that it's
never going to go away you're always
going to have animals going extinct
you're always going to have natural
disasters you're also always going to
you're always going to have viruses that
are out there that could become
epidemics or pandemics
all of that stuff is always there
it's just a question of focus what do
you choose to focus on
and in our culture in the media age it's
the media that decides what we focus on
and this is really this is this is the
nature of media propaganda much of the
time
now yeah they do we we hear about fake
news and and they do invent stories
sometimes and then there are other
stories that are half invented in half
not you know they kind of fictionalize
it's sort of based on a true story
but much of what they tell us
is
basically true it's just but the the the
fake news part of it comes in from what
they choose to focus on
so they're kind of they're giving you
bits of information that might be mostly
accurate
but the question is what are they
leaving out
and that's that's the way it generally
works
all right this is from Yahoo the latest
environmentalist trend is here pouring
out milk in grocery stores all across
the UK teenagers concerned about the
environment are doing milk pores the new
trend involves going into grocery stores
picking up cartons of cow produced milk
and pouring out their contents according
to Animal Rights group animal Rebellion
videos that have popped up on social
media show teens pouring milk onto the
floor over sales counters and elsewhere
in the store
this group says quote
the dairy industry is incredibly
environmentally destructive the world's
top five meat and dairy corporations are
now responsible for more ghg emissions
than Exxon shell or BP we need a
plant-based future now
now so we we just saw on Friday
those uh self-entitled uh
environmentalist brats who you know went
to an art gallery and poured tomato soup
on a van Gogh painting and uh now
they've moved on to this let's watch one
of these videos here
[Music]
on fire
well they're allowed to stay in there
and simply dump all the milk out
no one is stopping okay here's one guy
he's trying to reason with that but
they're not they don't care
[Music]
oh and he's now we're just gonna walk
away
[Music]
oh he has an employee he's got the
headset on
[Music]
okay how about actual security
come and grab these girls and drag them
out that's one strategy we could think
about
[Music]
we're going to drag these no they don't
no one takes them out they're allowed to
so you've got the British store clerks
there very politely they would you would
you mind coming no they're just gonna
ignore him
this is the theme today self-entitled
brats who suffer no consequences
and you know something else about this
the left-wing activism
especially when especially left-wing
environmental activism
the people who suffer the most from it
the people who have to pay the
consequences for it it's always like
minimum wage blue collar workers
because there's a there's a you know a
janitor at that grocery store who's
gonna have to clean all that up that's
the only person you're punishing you're
not punishing the dairy farms
but they've already getting they already
made their money off of that
the only person you're punishing is the
janitor who now has to go and clean up
all the milk
same thing with the environmentalists
when they go and they they clog up
traffic who are you punishing when you
clog up traffic you sit in the middle of
the street
not punishing the uh oil companies
you're punishing people that have to get
to work
and the frustrating thing is that all of
this could be easily solved
could be easily solved with consequences
you know the only reason why these
people do this is because they know that
there's not going to be any serious
consequences
you start putting serious consequences
in place and most of this just goes away
and that's the case with
the environmentalist vandalism that's
the case with uh most the crime in the
city's serious consequences and this
stuff stops
what's the consequence here first of all
you physically drag them out
and then for them you put them in jail
for I don't know
for them you know like probably a month
would do it
severe fine give them some jail time
drag them out
we're not doing that again
no consequences at all and you end up
with this and you're going to get a lot
more of it too now let's get to our
comment section
s
[Music]
Annie says luckily the van Gogh painting
is okay also those two have been
arrested hopefully they get charged for
a good amount of time for vandalism uh
okay it's good if they were able to
salvage the painting I hadn't heard that
so that's good news
um I would expect that they were at
least arrested
okay but we're not quite at the point
where you could do that and not even be
arrested for it but uh yeah they were
arrested the question is do they
actually get prison time for it and I
find that really hard to believe
there should be there should be serious
prison time I said on Friday 15 years in
prison I didn't mean that as a joke
you are attempting to damage something
that is priceless
um
and a a society that is serious about
itself about its art about its culture
its history
would bring down the hammer on people
like that but I I just don't see it
happen Daniel says Matt are you
practicing your WNBA cheerleader cheers
uh yeah I mean no I'm not practicing
them does the WNBA even have
cheerleaders I wasn't aware of that if
they do I have to assume that they
recruit their cheerleaders from like
acting schools because it would it would
take a real acting performance to
pretend that you're excited about the
WNBA each night uh but I guess I'll I
don't know I'll find out if they have
cheerleaders because I am certainly
going to come in last place in our
fantasy football league
and I have to admit that I am deeply
regretting
my life choices at this point
uh I knew that I wouldn't update my team
or pay attention to it I knew that going
in I said that I said that all along
and I followed through I followed
through on not following through on
fantasy football which is what I said
would happen
and at first when it was uh this idea of
the loser has to go to wmea game when it
was just an idea and it was a
hypothetical
I I you know I sort of resigned myself
to it and I thought it was a funny idea
there's no question about it yet now
it's closely becoming an actual reality
and I'm feeling this kind of creeping
dread oh I'm being told that WNBA does
have cheerleaders okay are they female
or is it a do they do male cheerleaders
for the
males iffyness okay
tough job not a job I'd want to do
the worst part
though about this you have to understand
is that the nearest WNBA team this is
the other thing I didn't realize this
when we originally agreed to the WNBA
punishment I didn't realize that the
nearest WNBA team is like five hours
away
so this isn't even just a quick joke
where you head down to the local WNBA
stadium and you're back in a few hours I
thought that's what it would be I
thought I figured that the WNBA they
play their games down at the local uh
YMCA gymnasium and uh and you go you're
there back in two hours because
obviously you don't have to worry about
crowds or traffic or anything like that
but now it now I realize it's gonna be
like a two-day Excursion this is an
overnight deal
I'm gonna have to leave for the night
and how am I going to explain that to my
wife
so she has to stay back with the kids so
that I can go to a WNBA game
because I lost a fantasy football league
so not only do I have to go to a WNBA
game but I'm gonna have to I'm gonna
have an annoyed wife to deal with on top
of it it's just it's not it's not fair
if I could send my wife instead could
she pin [ __ ] for me
although I wouldn't want to do that
because then she might enjoy it somehow
she might come back and she's now like a
big WNBA fan and so then I've I've
replaced a a night of misery for a
lifetime of pain and so I can't do that
I'm just stuck with it there's nothing I
can do
um drink water says as a student at uh I
appreciate you coming uh I appreciate
you for coming to speak Matt left wing
students are livid on campus right now
it's hilarious but also sad to see as
far as I can tell the student body in
this University is largely left-wing so
me and other conservatives get called
names if we go against their agenda I'm
lucky enough to be a person of color so
they don't always call me a KKK member
as much as they do some other white
conservative students I'm sorry these
people made us look so bad also somehow
the anti-trans transphobia group
is calling their work last night a
success even though all they did is act
like children whining and screaming
about fascism when they're in fact the
real fascists why is it so much to ask
for them to just leave others especially
kids alone
well if you could send me so I didn't
realize this so it doesn't surprise me
but the left-wing groups
at University of Houston I guess they're
spiking the football and saying was a
big success if you have any screenshots
of that I'd love to see it so I could
join in the laugh
the event happened uh we had hundreds of
people there sold out crowd
and uh it was great then we went we went
home it was fine
that's a success for them
all right if that's the kind of success
you you want to claim for yourself I I
won't I won't take it away from you
Jeremy's razors is currently having a 40
off fall sale through national no beard
day October 18th 2022 national no beard
day
well I can't I like in good conscience I
can't even be a part of this stop giving
her money to woke razor companies that
hate you shave with the jammies razors
instead purchase a Founder shave kit for
40 off plus free shipping which brings
the price below 30 visit
jeremesraisers.com to save today I feel
morally compromised now now let's get to
our daily cancellation
thank you
daily cancellation I must come to the
defense of a fellow YouTuber and
commentator Sydney Watson was the
subject of Internet outrage over the
weekend it generated critical critical
headlines in the media after she
complained about her experience on an
American Airlines flight where she was
stuck for several hours between two
morbidly obese passengers now it all
began with this tweet thread published
in helpless anguish a few days ago in
which Watson writes quote I am currently
literally wedged between two obese
people on my flight this is absolutely
not acceptable or okay if if fat people
want to be fat fine but it's something
else entirely when I'm stuck between you
with your arm rolls on my body for three
hours
she continues I don't care if this is
mean my entire body is currently being
touched against my wishes I can't even
put the armrest down on either side
because there's no effing room I'm sick
of acting like fatness to this extent is
normal let me assure you it is not I'm
so effing mad I don't even have words if
you need a seat belt extender you are
too fat to be on a plane buy two seats
or don't fly I said to the man hey we
can swap seats if you'd like to sit
together his sister is on my left he
says no that's okay
and then I started shrieking internally
now in photos taken secretly though not
revealing the other passengers faces you
can actually see that their bodies are
in fact
spilling over into her seat squeezing
her in on either side in fact they have
so much oversized baggage attached to
their physical frames that Watson can't
even put her tray table down there's
another photo if I try to put the tray
table down and one of their stomachs is
like in the way and she can't put it
down this is very much like the scene in
Star Wars where Luke and Leia wind up in
a trash compactor that nearly crushes
them to death except in this case the
trash compactor is made out of sweaty
human flesh and thus is far more
horrifying also if memory serves me I
think C-3PO bailed them out of that jam
but Sydney Watson had no one to rescue
her not even after the fact when
American Airlines responded to her
complaints with this this was their
response their official company response
quote our passengers come in all
different sizes and shapes or sorry you
were uncomfortable on your flight period
of course if your luggage weighs one
pound over 50 American Airlines will
charge you a hundred extra dollars if it
weighs over 100 pounds you can't bring
it on the flight at all so luggage is
not allowed to come in all shapes and
sizes but a passenger can take up one
and a half seats
and the poor sapo gets stuck with the
half seat just has to deal with it
apparently
this is the view of American Airlines
and of the American Media which as
mentioned blasted Watson for fat shaming
the bulbous individuals who nearly
suffocated her but as always the media
and the outrage mob have gotten this one
entirely wrong
it is perfectly reasonable and
appropriate
for Sydney Watson to complain about this
and and the reason why it's reasonable
is very simple
she paid for a seat on the airplane
she she paid for the entire width of the
seat
she paid for the privilege of occupying
that assigned space and she paid a lot
of money even if it's a a crappy middle
seat she still paid a lot of money
because flying is not cheap
the obese people on either side of her
are taking space that does not belong to
them and that they did not pay for
so she is indeed the aggrieved party in
this case she is entirely in the right
in fact she is obviously self-evidently
in the right
it is absurd to expect a person to
simply be okay with having someone
else's body to people's bodies as it
happens wedged against theirs for
several hours in a row
you're flying on a plane not attending
an orgy
this kind of physical intimacy should
not be part of the bargain
it's only become a standard feature of
the air travel experience because for
one thing the airlines treat their
passengers like livestock and for
another
so many passengers these days in terms
of size are not far off from livestock
no offense it's an untenable situation
made all the worse when it's cloaked in
the language of body positivity
but really it's got nothing to do with
any of that
this all stems from a total lack of
concern for fairness for health
and for the comfort and well-being of
paying customers
and it's also a symptom of a of a common
problem in our culture
one that we talk about a lot on the show
where time and time again
we encounter a situation
where somebody has to be out of luck
right it's a zero-sum kind of contest
someone has to be inconvenienced someone
has to be made uncomfortable
someone has to be the loser in the
situation and when that happens we
always choose the wrong person to lose
we always give the Short Straw to the
exact person who should not be forced to
draw it
and we do this without even
acknowledging that we're doing it in the
case of air travel we can either require
that morbidly obese people pay for first
class or for multiple seats
or simply forbid them from buying
tickets at all if they can't fit into
one seat or or we can force normal size
customers to give up a third or half of
their seats and have their personal
space invaded and be unable to use the
features of the plane they paid for and
forced them to be uncomfortable and
miserable for their the entirety of
their flight
those are the two options it has to be
one or the other
the morbidly obese passenger creates a
situation where someone has to be the
loser someone has to come out on bottom
and someone has to be inconvenienced
and it's incredibly obvious that the the
someone in this case should be the
morbidly obese passenger who has created
the situation in the first place
but instead just as we do with boys who
want to access the girls locker room and
with many other similar situations we
say that the person creating the problem
should be exempt from its consequences
while innocent bystanders should be
forced to Bear the burden
it's completely backwards and ridiculous
that's the situation that's that's the
thing
when you when you are morbidly obese
and you get on an airplane
it you are creating a situation that
didn't exist before
and someone's going to have to suffer
the consequences unfortunately for that
now I say this even though I I do have
sympathy for morbidly obese people
I wouldn't want to be in that sort of
physical state myself
but the reality is that it's a physical
state you have to put yourself in
nobody who exerts even the mildest
effort to eat healthy and exercise will
end up 200 pounds overweight
okay it might be difficult to if you
want to stay in good shape especially as
you get older yeah that takes sacrifice
that's difficult
but to simply not be 200 pounds
overweight that takes very little effort
now if it's your choice to live that way
it's your choice to shoulder the
consequences
you can't demand that other people
shoulder it for you
and that is why Sydney Watson is not
canceled today but her critics in fact
are
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]